I couldn't cut my hair James that's not
an expense you could not have I couldn't
cut my hair
I said that because that was that was an
expense I couldn't afford I had to pay
for travel that was a luxury brother I
needed the money for the train
[Music]
all right my G's back with another
Banger and as you know we go straight
into the IG question and as per usual
juicy juicy juicy and the question of
the week was
when did you realize your partner was
broke I actually stumbled across because
sometimes I told you before some of
those people send me stuff like say I
was asking the question and I saw the
question do you like this just once just
one he said you saw it right off in it
yeah what was it I don't know it looked
like a bristle you did look like a
bristle yeah they're like next man's
hair
yeah it is oh
nah bro what even is that yuck
um but yeah you were saying uh yeah
someone said this to me
um and I read the question I was like
bang it yeah yeah when did you find out
your partner was broke obviously did any
guys reply yeah bear what to be fair
we've got a lot more women than men yeah
of course of course because they stay
realizing because that's all they think
about
there's only thing about all they care
but it's like all right as per use just
gonna reel them off yeah when did you
realize your partner was broke plot
twist I'm the broke one first one wow
what twist I'm the broke one yeah
ah yeah
when I found messages on his phone of
him begging my mum for money for
Valentine's Day
her mom
begging begging please miss X she'll
leave me you know she will your daughter
what you guys have spoken about this so
please give me the money you've spoken
about agnosium like I know she wants to
leave you know your daughter as well as
Isaac run me the money run me the money
please for Valentine's Day begging oh
that's so embarrassing bro hello hello
when I asked him for some Victoria
Secret and he said that's not for us
afford that
primary or Nom that's not for us oh bro
there's certain Lots in life that you
shouldn't have to accept yeah living in
England is so toxic do you know what I
mean because it's like
why do I have to be broke yes why do I
have to be what do you mean that's not
for us that's mental and then like
women know that like if they're paying
enough it can be for me if I want it to
be it will be obviously to understand if
you're for me
Victoria's Secret in my life and I'm
going to get it yeah that's not my
problem anymore it's your problem yeah
you're either a barrier or you're not
facts you're ever with me against me
yeah so make more money please please I
shouldn't even have to ask this question
but make more money because I need to
feel pretty facts wow it's long it's
tough It's a tough tough tough world we
live in
she lied about working from home then
tried to cash a check that she printed
out
printed out is this catching me if you
can
swear lied about working from home
she's just she's just poor and jobless
she's just about yeah she's printing
checks that's crazy
that's crazy on a HP Inkjet
probably yes wow probably that's good
yeah
probably Jesus probably yeah that's a
new level of broke it is that's low
that's low
uh when money started going missing
after she stayed the night I started to
sleep with one eye open
money just started to go missing
first of all why we got money this is
why we gotta keep money in the house
just keep cash around
it's just going missing it's just going
missing that's Peak I'm sleeping I slept
with one eye open yeah yeah
when he tried to give me tap water
[Music]
that's out of order
some people drink tap water depends on
what what part of England you live in
Santa was acceptable certain type was
not yeah bro when he tried to give me
tap water yeah like wow you're broke
not even spring
not even filtered from the fridge yeah
yeah tap tap yuck yeah wishes water
he's trying to give me Rishi juice
I lent him some money and he used it to
buy a chain off Amazon that eventually
turned green of course it turned green
bro that's enough a chain of Amazon
how badly do we need a chain in general
how important is a chain that we're
shopping on Amazon Wild
when she got caught stealing pregnancy
tests
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jesus fam when I was trying to work from
home and his house ran out of
electricity
okay
you know what
first of all I've been broke before
everyone's been broken I know we'll talk
about after
but your ass running out of electricity
is not necessarily your fault it doesn't
mean you're broke it just means you're
not monitoring yeah the key card thing
you're not monitoring it that one that
[__] turns off
I'm gonna tell you when that [__] turns
off there's not a frustration like yeah
that gas as well mid shower used to
happen to me all the time brother listen
to me I'm getting vexed bro I'm getting
vexed bro that's hilarious two things
that used to happen all the time yeah
one I'll be running Call of Duty with
these man yeah
middle of the night they need to have
rules after 9 p.m you're not locking it
off yeah okay that needs to be a rule
there's nothing I can do because the
Shop's closed bro I'll be on Call of
Duty
whole thing's done
no whole Flat's done no and you're like
cool
cool hopefully I've got that emergency
yes hopefully your boy's got an
emergency but sometimes I'm already on
emergency they say I'll merge you five
or ten yeah I'm gonna have emergency
five and that's gone it's a wrap looks
like we're sleeping in silence
no fans tonight that's hilarious bro
that's number one yeah John the second
one because your boy likes to steam the
room in the bathroom before he gets in
the shower and you know this
a man said you know this
you know Daddy likes to exfoliate and
open up his paws before he jumps in the
water so what I like to do
so what I like to do is Crank That on 38
yeah
and let the steam marinate while I'm
broke it while my cheeks are spread on
the toilet and Tick Tock is Flowing I'm
having a morning do I mean this is my
morning routine I love it
them times
the gas will click off yeah I would wipe
flush the toilet dive in the shower
freezing in there
freezing in there that's ruined your
morning and that's when I used to have
to commute to work I don't have time to
go to the shop and get electric and come
back and shower so I'd have to put on
dirty clothes pack my suit whatever I
was wearing on the hangar and go to the
gym and shower my ass at the gym bro
oh embarrassing and I was at David Lloyd
so they'd give you a towel I'd be like
oh you're here early yeah yeah yeah yeah
run me on my towel taking my suit into
the shower and I'll be back out five
minutes and they're like yeah you didn't
even train yeah you used to you came
here for the shower yeah yeah yeah you
actually disgusted that's mad um
speaking of the electricity just
dwindling yeah you man haven't stepped
foot in in Lagos that's why you might
have a step foot in Lagos that's normal
so what that's normal really it's called
NAPA NAPA just takes they take like when
they won right really when they won we
could be chilling Sunday afternoon 3 P.M
watching a happy family movie 305 cotton
you might not get back for six hours you
might not get back in two what it
depends on them no it depends on them
obviously there's backup generators and
stuff if you can afford a generator and
everyone can forward a generator in
Nigeria
um yeah then you've got electricity back
up if not you just have to wait until
the power's running through your ends
again
facts bro that's not it's not jira
considered a developed country no no
okay no no no no it's a serious ledc
yeah it's a serious ledc
bro that's long man seriously yeah that
electric and gas that used to smoke me
it's mad bro I was livid but yeah back
to it when did you realize your partner
was broke
the only cash he had was coins
I don't remember losing my touch the
coin to be fair I'm not saying I'm rich
but I don't remember last time I touched
the coin the only I have one pound coin
in my car because I use it for the
trolleys in ASDA so that's the only time
I have coins in my car sales yeah yeah I
don't have coins
when they started to buy off-brand
cereal oh that's that's you can taste
the difference no bro of course is it
Tesco that's cool taste the difference
uh was it so Tesco's finest Sainsbury's
tasted different words
yeah no it's mad no you could never
I bet they put it in that clear
container as well
yeah yeah yeah so you think you've got
cocoa pops but you've got like cocoa
popsicles
and Cocoa Puffs yeah because the
chocolate drains from it immediately
pour the milk in the things clear it's
Rice Krispies in there uh do you
remember the dirtiest cereal Sugar Puffs
bro I actually never had those but I do
remember the thing with the line in the
middle I do remember them the dirty of
course Alice likes it of course Ellis
likes it you're so white sometimes bro
I'm sorry I've said it before but [__]
my life no one likes sugar cuffs
[__] I never had those but I do remember
them clearly
I'm sure there were Kellogg's I think
there might be yeah
um yeah bro sugar fuss of Butters but
yeah those costs so you know what
someone messing me the other day well
because we were speaking a while ago
about uh how expensive uh crunching our
clusters are yeah they're like three
pounds yeah someone was like chocolate
swells yeah yes Benny fam yeah someone
chat with me the other day uh say the
other day this was months ago when we
spoke about it almost like bro I bought
this expensive I'll see what we man I'm
talking about it's Butters I was like
what it's the it's categorically the
nicest thing it's all made it's cereal
yeah it's this that is serious yeah
that's the definition of definition so
every cluster is like you know when you
go Cinema and you get the purely sugar
popcorn yeah yeah and it crunches in
your mouth that's like every cluster
yeah facts with chocolate yeah whoever
said that your captain Oh Yeah there
that's cereal bro that's true born
cereals no wonder they're so expensive
whatever anyway why they broke
we went on vacay and he didn't even
pretend to bring his wallet
it just said bro I'm coming yeah we're
there mad I remember once I got sorry
for everything today I remember one time
my mom was moving wild okay I was like
13. maybe less okay no yeah about 13
foot no probably about 14. okay
my dad was taking a snowboard in office
holiday I've had until now
um sorry this uh somewhere in France
okay perfect time if anyone's never been
skiing or snowboarding before and you're
thinking about going going the Easter
holidays bro it's hot but obviously
there's snow yeah yeah first of all you
get a tan it's not good because you've
got tacos and [__] yeah but it's hot so
you can snowboard in your T-shirt bro
you get the jacket wrapped around here
soap on your T-shirt oh wow it's warm
and you just
the the thing is Puffy okay the snow is
the snow is perfect yeah yeah and then
it starts to melt at the lower ends as
well in the afternoon starts to melt
you'll see people like skiing down the
hill and they'll lean back and just ski
water ski across the puddle oh and then
keep scaring it's the sickest thing
you'll see okay say less anything
we have to pack it okay
um so anyway when
uh and on my way there my dad was no
this is when my dad was picking us up
the weekend that we were going okay I
think we're going on the Sunday and this
was the day before my dad's trying to
get us all the equipment okay my mom
asked my dad like ah
um
how much is all this gonna cost not like
she was paying for it but yeah how much
is all going to cost my dad's like oh
the suits are expensive they're like a
couple bills each for like the coat and
the thing it's so expensive
um she was like what what
and then she was like oh you're you man
because I didn't want to go you didn't
want I didn't want to go because back
then when I was a kid yeah yeah yeah it
didn't sound appealing to me I just want
to do roller coasters and swimming pools
what's this cold yeah your dad's trying
to teach you something yeah yeah
and plus this is when he just got with
my stepmom I wasn't really checking for
her and it was her idea yeah yeah yeah
yeah already you're buying it about a
whole day he was like oh
um such as such and such says um you
might enjoy going snowboarding and I was
like [__] that yeah even though I'm out
of here [__] her yeah
that sounds live but I was thinking of
[__] that yeah yeah I don't care what
she says I don't care what your new wife
says
laughs
hilarious I was a teen yeah yeah
hilarious I don't care what she has to
say why is she making suggestions about
our holidays why is she even coming
anyways wasn't there my mom had us up in
the car you know when you exchange cars
yes I mean the back of my dad's car her
face is in the window and she was like
this whole wallet thing she was like did
you bring your what did you bring your
pocket money and I was like No And she
was like so who's paying for all the
food I'm thinking brother
my mom said it to me and my brother she
was like yo this is how I know you're
spoiled brav you're just expecting your
dad to just pay for everything on this
holiday I was like yes I go to school
hey I make like two pounds a week in
pocket money
for my food in the week like what's
going on yeah yeah shut up
she was she was chatting to me like she
was a scorned girlfriend and I'm broke
yeah yeah I couldn't believe it I
couldn't tell I couldn't believe it wow
head was edge up in the window she was
like you man I'm so [__] spoiled
enjoy your holiday I'll say raw did you
bring your bucket did you bring your
pocket money
suspend or what and she said to spend on
food what bucket money's for
eign
that's hilarious that's hilarious uh
back to it when did you realize your
partner was broke
when I left the hoodie at hers and she
sold it to go to Nando's
pardon
I'ma keep it moving when our landlord
reached out to me to complain that the
rent wasn't paid
that's tough this is a girl yeah so he's
he was in charge of red and he's just
not getting paid landlord wreath the
reach out to me sweetly the landlord
reached out to me say on a Miss sorry to
bring this to your doorstep I know
you're not on the tendency someone under
this roof it's not paying stuff
and I'm sorry I had to bring to your
attention yeah I couldn't be confronted
with that
I couldn't be I couldn't come home from
work yeah on a la di da knowing the
bills haven't been paid and my wife just
shows me this email
I'll drop to my knees bro come on I will
drop to my knees because this facade has
gone on for a week now fam and you are
shopping for fish tanks
you're out shopping for fish tanks and
[__] and you ain't paying rent okay
what the [__] are you doing bro that's I
could that exactly confronted is the
word of choice
with my own waist like that like I
couldn't be faced with that
so the story doesn't cut it it really
doesn't and your priorities aren't in
check yeah well you're moving like
you've got money Rags yeah yeah you're a
liar that's what you are
he won't have a room
it's all long it's all long wow
when he would take the change at a
restaurant despite me paying the bill
wow that's a new level of low yeah
that's a bit buzz when he was hesitating
to pay for tickets for a film that he
wanted to see hesitating
imagine that like oh quantumania's out
oh let's see let's go
and he's like ah
he extended his overdraft to buy us
pancakes
what he ex fam the way man's priorities
are not in check pancakes he contacted
the bank
says can you bump it to a 100 plus and
need to buy some pancakes pancakes
brother oh my God
I'm so grateful my
um my bank weren't [__] with me when
I was younger you have no idea how many
times I asked them to increase it I did
it better times I never I never build
them I did it online because you could
you could either do it on your app or do
online and I tried to online it failed
every single time I kept on trying every
single time because I was poor I was so
poor
mine was you could do it online but if
you've got rejected online they'll tell
you to go to the branch okay so Michael
rejected I was like I'm just gonna have
to go to the brunch I was scared I was
scared of conversation yeah and I think
it was that
I think I remember the first time I
extended it it was a start off at 200 I
extend it to a grand so me and Amanda
could go on holidays
yeah to this day I haven't seen that
money back
yeah
does it say I've not seen that money
back from them man anyway we move
um and then I try to extend it again
when we're in uni um to like two grand
or even 1500 because I I was so poor
yeah yeah and every time they were like
no
funny story actually mine was originally
1500 I remember I think this was when I
started college maybe but
um one of my friends that worked a girl
on the market also had a side drop not
side job her side job was below the
market her main job she worked at HSBC
hmm she patented she before I moved to
Manny she patted me enough really yeah
yeah mine went from
one five to four five before I moved to
money yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
why you were in debt in Manchester
d-e-b-t brother capital d-e-b-t I
couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe it
as good as Manny was to me yeah hell on
us yeah I know I remember [__] I
remember because that was when I was
getting paid weekly and I was living a
lavish I couldn't believe it I was only
making like three bills a week but it
weren't making sense what do you mean
I'm getting money every Tuesday
every single Tuesday it doesn't matter
what goes wrong yeah yeah yeah next week
I'm covered bam I was Pat I remember
coming up some money you just filled
your fridge I never felt more of a man
I filled your fridge as I know you're
suffering at it let me patent you let's
go as done let's go now
[Laughter]
because I needed it fun let's go now
that's hilarious as soon as they
switched out from weekly to monthly yeah
wow because it's mad because I I
remember going from weekly to monthly
going from bartending to managing and
this was before you had gone from
sweeping this morning I said to you
parole remember to save a couple bags or
a couple hundred I remember because
those three four weeks yeah you're not
getting paid Prada I remember I could
have cut my hair until I've gotten paid
James that's not an expense you could
not have I couldn't cut my hair
I said that because that was that was an
expense I couldn't afford I had to pay
for travel that was a luxury brother I
needed the money for the train
I could have cut my hair
[Laughter]
oh yeah switching from weekly to monthly
so that's made me laugh so much bro
it must have been microphone thing bro I
remember because you taught me to save I
had five bills saved yeah and I was
thinking why am I saving this these men
ain't changing nothing yeah I went to
Grenada for a week spunk the whole five
bills came back to an email
same we've changed it from today
I think I I genuinely think I remember
yes do you have yes I had to survive a
month or nothing
I physically couldn't believe it I
begged my brother for money every week
and the third week he just said no
it could have been I was crying I'm your
brother I was like bro please he said
you're not good for it brother no
brother you're not good for it ah I'm
not just gonna keep giving you money
you're actively not good for it
all
right I've got a couple more when did
you realize your partner was broke
uh we had a lunch date scheduled and
when we met he said you know you're
paying right oh God Butters
I still have access to my ex's email and
this woman can't get a job to save her
life
I feel like someone sent me that oh so
separately elsewhere yeah yeah yeah no
no someone sent me a different thing it
wasn't that but it was some guy sent me
a thing yesterday and was like
um
what was it
literally like I've still got access to
my ex's email
um I went in on it the other day and she
can't even get a second interview at
Walmart
damn that's tough ah damn that's that's
the ugliest thing I can yeah because you
start looking at them different yeah
yeah yeah I mean you might look Buffy
yeah yes guys you're pathetic that's the
word I was looking for yeah
you might look nice but you're actually
pathetic yeah it was embarrassing wow
yeah okay I got three more I used the
toilet at his house and he didn't have
any toilet roll so he handed me a dish
cloth
a dish cloth [__] disgusting that's
different levels of this game yeah yeah
that's what that's too thick that's
great first of all that's two things
that's rough as [__] nah
I asked to borrow five dollars and his
hand started to tremble as he drew for
his wallet
that's a Pursuit happiness thing
I had 20 or so yeah
yeah oh I felt so bad for Willing same I
was thinking how can you ask him for
money you know he hasn't got it bro you
know he hasn't got it same will couldn't
he couldn't be like hey he couldn't he
couldn't he couldn't what you haven't
got 20 you ever got 20 quid bro why are
you here yeah how are you making it into
work every day what's going on he was
literally shaking yeah I gave him that
money back at the end I said yeah yeah
yeah yeah good that was mate that was
amazing good movie
um last one when I caught him stealing
money from me just to take me out
um so obviously we've gone back and
forth when did you realize you were
broke
when did I realize I was broke
um probably
the time I couldn't cut my hair bro
that's that's beyond broke yeah yeah no
that's I think there were two times so
switching from uh weekly to monthly was
the first time
no no no I've told the story wrong so
that still happened there was a time I
couldn't cut my hair yeah but it wasn't
going from
um weekly to monthly it was
leaving uni not having a job and then
starting Grill on the market that was
when I couldn't cut my hair because
obviously we won't get paid anything no
burst United everything was done I
didn't have a job my parents don't give
me money I was like I need a job and you
need to work for like a month no I need
a job man I think the I didn't get my
first pay until like maybe two weeks
because I like the admin process
only money I had was money for my Oyster
card at the time that's all I had no I
was spreading at work
I was eating at work traveling back home
planned for two weeks it was two solid
weeks my hair was dirty brother they
would have been thinking why did we
employ you yeah my hair was done when I
got paid and I think
I don't think it was yeah it obviously
it was weaker because I was bartender
yeah yeah I got paid after two weeks and
I got the trim I was like oh I could
breathe again yeah I could breathe again
wow I think that's the one that comes to
mind straight away because we were
talking about prior but yeah what about
you oh uh when did I realize I was broke
I've I've got literally 300 examples of
when I was [__] Baroque you know for
sure uni
um these electric and gas times I'm
talking about when I ran out of the
emergency and I was like wow okay okay
yeah I think I remember one time I knew
I was broke because I had to top up the
gas by eight pounds not even a whole ten
not not even a tenor not 20 not thirty
eight pounds eight yeah and I was like
wow wow wow wow I'm living on every
penny I need to account for everything
morsel of money that goes in and out of
my account and I remember
um
that was obviously there's a bait time
uni doesn't really count though because
everyone's broke so you can scream from
from the heavens that you're broken uni
and you'll still get [__] you know what
I mean
I wasn't expecting you to say that but
yeah I know what you mean yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't matter but yeah the worst the
worst the most time I was was when I um
one when I had to steal that girl's
money
to get a taxi home yep broke yep
um and two was when I took that girl to
Nando's and had she I ordered a quarter
chicken and chips cost like seven pounds
at the time that's all I had and you
prayed she didn't I had 11 pound in my
account I ordered my meal for seven
pounds it came on a baby plate
it came on a baby plate
and after I ordered yeah I told her
order and then I stood behind her in the
queue yeah and then I ran to the toilet
and then came back and ordered mine oh
my she had a full-on meal I had a little
baby team but it's also do or die in
them situations because you knew you
were bro but you knew you had to go on
this day there's nowhere exactly there
was no way and my financial
circumstances aren't going to change
next week
is now or never and also that's how I
know you went thinking straight because
you've told your story but maybe two or
three times and every single time REM
says why do you just ask one of us oh
yeah you remember in it that never even
came into my head no you weren't
thinking I wasn't you were just thinking
I need to go on this date now yeah yeah
yeah now whatever you might have say it
to me is just barriers
your office your haters bro you don't
think I deserve a go like this and I do
I'm going on the day I don't want to
hear it
hilarious bro oh my god I've been broken
my day I've been broke in my day yeah
fam that's wild I remember
um this is what our newest broke as well
this again it was in uni my dad had this
massive like Satchel of change bro okay
so my dad would always this is uh years
ago
obviously we're in uni and he had this
like this Satchel that he used like a
laptop bag okay and you would always
Dash change in there this [__]
had must have had 300 pound in change in
this bag he was never do anything about
it so it'd obviously go cash point spend
his cash change change back change back
more cash more cash but I couldn't
believe it because back then I was just
using all the coins yes I couldn't
believe it so sometimes on if I was
lucky if I went to visit my dad on a
weekend I'd say Dad can I grab some
change out your bag
um
and he'd be like yeah I would go with
two hands
I'm going there so it was spilling out
on my hands I don't think you get it the
coins will be spilling out of my head
and I would exclusively pick the two
pound coin
and I'd be thinking bro I've been
thinking this is 30 questions I'm
Panda's week from coins yeah yeah yeah
that's true and pattern from coins yeah
that's crazy embarrassing that's my food
for this week yeah yeah yeah I can't
wait
humiliating oh that's hilarious and I
remember the last time I knew it was
broke was when
I was out in a club and I had to I
couldn't drink till after midnight
because our student loan hit my bank at
midnight
wow I couldn't drink till midnight and
then soon as I hit midnight I ran out
went to the cash point saw the student
loan and hit drapes 50 Quid out there
and had the time of my life
but I I was in there from like 10 yeah
yeah wow
wow yeah we've we've lived different
lives boy we have wow welcome back guys
thank you for coming back to the show
happy Monday as always it's an honor to
have you here always um and as always
guys please please please head on over
to patreon.com shits and gigs for some
extra content for some
true indoctrination into our cult baby
culture okay the Log Cabin tour is
underway and we need all the babies to
show face okay if we're gonna make this
a worldwide thing we need funds we turns
out we need funds so what we're going to
give to you is three years worth of
content that you can binge through we're
gonna give you an episode every Thursday
we're going to give you a Discord
channel that you can Vibe with all the
other cult babies and all we ask in
return is three pound a month 10 for
your day you need to run the pizza sng
um run the PTO cult daddies and yeah
you're either with us or against us
apparently
facts apparently you'll be this against
that also there is another UK podcast
right it's called have a word they're
based in Liverpool and they just hit 20
000 patrons they're killing on patreon
they're crushing it we need to smack
them yeah we're like 11 000 something
right now which is unbelievably good
fantastic it's absolutely fantastic it's
unbelievably good it's smash through
every expectation we ever have for
patreon okay we've got one of the
biggest patrons in this country fax
that's actual facts that's actually a
fact we chat a lot of [__] but that's
actually true it's crazy we've got one
of the biggest
um in the entire country yeah and that
is unbelievable but we want to be the
biggest factual they're the biggest [__]
those guys let's smash through them all
right guys head on over to patreon.com
guys obviously if you are watching on
the YouTube channel we're on Mission One
Millie
um we should have by now we should have
hit 600k by the time this comes out
um moving crazy that's also unbelievable
so again guys subscribe to the channel
hit the notification Bell
um and guys if you're listening on any
of the platforms please leave us a nice
review
um five stars is preferable
but you know what say how you feel how
you really really feel
right before we get into the
nitty-gritty guys
for the last few weeks I've been doing
Jay Shetty style introductions
style introductions to remind them I did
Ellis a few weeks ago gave his origin
story Into the SMG gang I gave uh my OG
experiences with REM then also forgot to
even tell the world why he's here
um but apart from that there's no reason
to turn wise here because he's here
because of all the reasons that I gave
facts that's literally facts he's here
there you go because he's the langest
human there you go today's about fuhad
right
this one's gonna be a good one I'm
blushing already you're gonna cry
you're gonna cry your stupid little eyes
so dramatic say what you want to say
cool so right let me introduce Fire Lord
flakes to you guys if you're new here
get to know right come on so obviously I
met fuhad I'm not gonna go through the
whole Spiel right I met a few who had
years and years ago we've been friends
ever since and when Foo had moved to
Manchester for work
I would make the effort every few weeks
to come and spend the weekend with him
and we'll go out and have a great time
and would catch up about old stories and
would literally just laugh and laugh and
laugh the same that we do here we just
laugh and laugh and laugh and laugh for
hours and hours and hours and it will
just be the most fun [__] ever thanks
um and I was obsessed with podcasting
and I asked him bro I really really want
to do a podcast mainly not even because
I was obsessed with podcasting for one I
thought podcasting is the coolest job in
the world
and for two
I thought
I need a reason I hated working so much
that I just needed a reason to believe
that I won't be working forever I didn't
necessarily think the podcast was ever
going to come of anything but I needed
hope
do you know what I mean yeah at that
moment I ever had no hope
and I couldn't just keep going to work
every day with no hope that's hilarious
sorry I asked an awesome food gave
perfectly justifiable reasons
he didn't digest podcast content he had
no interest in podcasts he had no
interest on being on camera he had no
interest in exposing his personal life
to strangers those are all reasonable
justifications I can't believe I said
all of those things bro wow he had no
interest in it and he was very very well
set he also had hope because he was on a
successful career path in Hospitality he
had no reason to think about uh side
hustles he had no reason to to have hope
for another thing because he was set he
was calm
um he just moved to this new city to
start this New Life and this new job and
this amazing restaurant he had no reason
to entertain my [__]
um but after months of convincing he
finally turned around and said you know
what [__] it let's do it and that's not
because he thought
this is going to make money this is
going to do this it's just because he's
a good friend
that's the only reason he did it is
because he's a good friend
and for the next two years from that
point
Foo had gave up every Monday
he used up all of his holiday work
holiday for me he gave up his Sunday
evenings there were times where he would
have to stay up until two o'clock in the
morning with me recording stuff he
spend hours and hours and hours of his
time
weeks and years of his time entertaining
my [__] dream
entertaining my [__] dream and gave
up literally everything
so much of his time and so much of his
effort just to entertain my [__] purely
because he's a good friend he didn't
make a single penny for [__]
literally years yeah
and he just did it because he said he
was going to do it and nope you had
every right six months in 12 months into
turn around and be like fan this is all
well and good but I can't be bothered
anymore it didn't cross my mind bro I
know because you're a real man yeah I
said it before bro you're a [__] real
man bro man's a man of his word is that
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna do it yeah two
years later he's still doing it three
years later he's caked three is that
he's cage so yeah obviously it worked
out yeah okay you're welcome
hilarious but for multiple years this
guy just did it on good faith and I have
never met an individual
but from now until then and forever that
will be willing to do that the way that
fuja did it and I am so happy
not just for my own life but the success
of this show I'm so happy that fuhad
gets this as a just
we could be the biggest show on planet
Earth and it wouldn't be enough of a
reward for the sacrifices this guy made
just to keep his best friend happy so
guys final flakes
that was beautiful thank you you're
welcome thank you what's up guys quick
break to ask this question are you ready
to make a New Year's resolution you can
actually keep
because our friends at Mass gate have
one for you it's called proper hygiene
[__] proper hygiene clean up okay now
the leaders in below the waist grouping
and Experts of men's hair removal have
you covered for your much needed
resolution of feeling your best join the
seven million men worldwide who trust
our guys over at manscapes with our
exclusive offer all you need to do is go
to myscape.com use the code sng Sierra
November Golf and that's going to get
you 20 off and free shipping worldwide
guys it's time to level up and fully
align your hygiene routine with the most
stylish and premium grooming products
out there right that's the bills paid
let's get back to the episode
um right you've got a quiz for us thank
you
um yes I do have a quiz uh so last week
we did
um top five spoken languages in the
world right this week we're gonna do top
five most populated countries in the
world top five most populated countries
oh interesting
um slight segue I got heat from the
Indian Community last week what because
that's a good write or something in it
I want to give you a [__] hey hey hey
hey hey I don't know about anything
there I was thinking on my feet yeah it
was under pressure I don't know about it
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um Okay cool so
as per usual give me the five and if if
you can give me
um the actual population closest to a
million you get bonus points oh [__] my
life just closer to a million it's not
obviously top five most populated
countries so first of all give me your
five give me your five give me a five
and it will run it back for population
for population okay numerics right
I'm gonna go China okay is this your
order are you give me a random fight I'm
giving you a random five okay let me
write yours down first right
all right China yeah India yep America
yep funnily enough I'm I'm feeling say
in Japan okay and
oh I guess um I'm thinking Russia but
Russia is a lot of empty space
are you looking at me for confirmation
yeah I know
um so I said four right you said four
you said China India America Japan
I'm gonna go a random one and say
like
maybe Germany Germany Sailors so your
top five or your five are China India
America Japan Germany cool REM what do
you say ah it's Gotta Be China China
um India India
I'll go USA as well yep Pakistan okay oh
that's a good shout okay son of a [__]
that's a probably a good shout although
you said it and it is a lot of random
open space I'll just say Russia off top
of my head just cool so you've gone it's
so also is yours a random five or is
this top like one to five so what did I
say you said I'll say yours back in your
order China India USA Pakistan Russia is
that your top five or is that random
five
I'd say the exact same is what James
said exactly she had the exact same in
my head so China India America Japan
Germany exactly exact same yeah I just
thought say less and now we have to do
close to a million yeah oh okay I'm
gonna say China is
2.1 billion 2.1 billion okay India is
one billion America actually know this
one actually I don't
360 million Japan I'm gonna say a
hundred million Germany oh see I don't
think Germany's in there now I'm saying
it I reckon Germany's like 70 million uh
REM China I don't know two Bill India
1.8 uh USA let's go random 750. well
Pakistan
600 mil Russia oh God
it's all gone wrong man wait
yeah yeah it's not nice it's all wrong
um well it's not as long as Germany but
yeah it's um let's say we'll see 500 mil
uh Alice I say China maybe like 2.2
India 100 Mil I don't even know a
hundred mil where no no that's too low
let the boy say what he wants to say I'm
just saying you're changing his answer
I'm changing his answer I said 100 Mil
yes and now he's saying it's too low no
it's locked I've already done my next
one all right cool America
600 mil
all right Japan let's go 100 as well 100
which have no idea and then you've got
Germany 200 200 amps cool yeah
okay right at the moment of truth how
was the scoring system
you get one point per correct country
and you get bonus points per closest to
million population right so it's a total
of 10 points you can get
so how do we judge closest to million if
we're the only one with that answer
so he's the only one with Pakistan so
he's going to get closest to million
because I didn't give an artificial but
that depends on where the Pakistan is in
the top five if it's not in the top five
then it's a zero yeah but if it is in
the top five he gets a point yeah and
then he could say there's two people in
Pakistan and get another point because
no one else is there okay so it has to
be if if the if there's like you said
Pakistan you sit back then closer all
right cool cool cool all right
that's cool so you unfortunately you
can't get a bonus Point Pakistan
basically right I'm just going to start
off by saying Germany's not in it all
right cool Jeremy's not even in the top
ten yeah all right but what I would say
you said 70 mil Germany's 83 mil so one
played that's really good that was great
thank you but it's not even in the top
10. all right cool
um I will give you number five which no
one said oh tell a lie number five
oh I wonder how can I do this bonus
system actually because the ranking
matters
okay you have one of top to five matters
all right and you've locked it in
go on
so Pakistan is number five [__] I knew
as soon as you said Pakistan I knew it
was in Pakistan is number five so well
played on getting it in your top five
but it's not
the fifth one it's not it's not where
you put in yeah and that the population
averaging 238 M's
yeah didn't even cross my mind when you
said I was containing my smile yeah as
soon as you said Pakistan I was like
it's a wrap yeah yeah oh 240 or 238 cool
I'll tally it properly at the end cool
uh number four
Indonesia which nobody got Indonesia
which nobody got 276 M's okay
tomorrow
number three
before you say anything now I know uh
USA is in there
I think it's number three and I know I
got close to a million
um you are right on all accounts sir so
USA is number three
um just for context you said 600 million
you said 750 million James said 360
million and drumroll
339 million
so yeah well played so I've got two
points right now you've got two points
you've got one rem's got none right now
because it's wrong order oh it has to be
the right order it has to be that's why
I said are you sure about that okay okay
okay okay okay okay
keep going
number two number two is sticky because
ah yeah number two oh that's just
changed yeah hold on huh that's my dog
that's your dub you think you got it I
think I got more points in here in
general
um yeah I think I will do all right this
is number two his number both of your
number yeah everyone's number two all
right cool everyone numbers two
everyone's number two was India yeah
um and you are all correct gang India is
second
uh just for context
1.8 billion
100 million shocking
shocking answer from you I'm gonna
[__] believe what you said and one
billion and the answer is
1.42 billion
ah voice is more than that for India
1.42 billion so it just leans slightly
closer to REM I think what did I say 1.8
he said 1.8 and I said one so 1.4 would
be smack bang yeah and it's 1.42 oh
yuck
cool and last but not least obviously
most populous China
um context you said 2.1 you said 2.2 you
said two Billy
drum roll
the answer is one point
four two five really yeah
so that's REM okay but yeah guys ping
right before we continue I want to talk
to you about this new accountability
thing on this so I always talk about my
accountability stuff or our
accountability stuff on patreon and I
thought you know what this time because
we had that call yesterday uh and one of
the patrons was like oh you all this
accountability chat is helping me she's
lost a stone yeah she's lost a stone
since December yep
um yeah I thought you know what let me
bring it to the Main Street the
mainstream so I started this thing the
other day right so as I said to you the
other week I'm I'm fed up
I'm fed up with the lack of consistency
I'm fed up with the just like just
everything up and down the time flow of
the hotel yeah just like I'm struggling
with the food so I get the meal plans
the meal plans aren't helping me because
they're [__] around a little bit I'm
struggling with the training uh I'm
doing a bit of basketball which is
[__] up my knees which is making my
training worse and like everything was
just going badly so I set myself into I
set myself kind of like a resolution but
not really okay I set myself a challenge
right so there I took inspiration this
is this is challenge called 75 hard okay
the name of it was 75 hard it's
impossible oh you know about Ellis 75
hearts a joke okay so basically the idea
of 75 hard is you've got 75 days yeah
75 days in a row well you have to do I'm
gonna butcher it but it's something like
two 45 minute exercises one of them
exercises two 45 minute workout sessions
a day one of them has to be outside you
have to drink like four liters of water
a day you have to read at least 10 pages
of like a self-development book every
day you have to
um do some other [__] as well and you
have to do it for 75 days and wrote if
you miss a day you have to start again
I thought you just have to spend that
day back you have to start the whole 75
days again so I've seen so many ticks on
people like failed failed failed failed
wow yeah hard bro
I'll let you continue but I feel like I
could be wrong but I think mosten's done
it but I don't think he did 75 you
remember more stood in for money
uh you used to work with me other black
um black guys slim managers yes I do not
I do it so
I'm sure he did something similarly it
might not have been a 75 dating but I
remember he was following a program
where he had to trade every single day
and do this extracurricular activities
mad when I saw his before and after yeah
I can imagine oh I I don't the thing
works yeah fam I can believe one million
percent yeah that if you can manage to
do the 7500 you're a different being
afterwards I think he may have done it
for three weeks to a month
right so my thing is
um
my thing is
um so I thought cool I'm not doing 75
hard because that's literally too hard
yeah
I was like you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna take this accountability to
the new level okay I'm gonna set myself
a few parameters a few tenants yeah
liver King Ting few ancestral tenants
that have to stick to okay
first one diet wise yep very easy
no uh bread no Dairy but I think bread
is easy but yeah no bread no Dairy bread
and pasta kind of fall into the same
thing for me I'm gonna try and sell for
pasta but no bread no Dairy yeah no uh
no bread no Dairy no what's the other
one I feel Sugar Sugar yeah sorry yeah
no bread no Dairy and sugar
that's it that's all I'm doing change it
to my no bread no Dairy no sugar that's
it gone
uh at least three liters of water a day
easy
um at least
45 minutes of exercise every single day
and uh whether that be indoors or
Outdoors whatever it is some kind of
exercise every single day yeah anything
um and was there anything else that that
that
um and
making sure that I'm digesting
self-development content every day
whether that be whether I've downloaded
an oh I've downloaded an audiobook okay
called uh it's written by a former Navy
SEAL called Jocko will Nick okay um I've
seen him on a few podcasts serious guy
the book is called Extreme ownership you
have to take accountability for
everything so now I'm one of my other uh
things on my thing is take extreme
ownership of everything everything that
goes wrong in my life is my fault
basically everything is my fault if this
is not working it's my fault if
REM rocks up an hour late it's my fault
because
this is my business and I haven't
instilled to REM here he needs to be
here 15 minutes early because that's
like that same if Ellis doesn't know to
get something done by Tuesday it's my
fault because of that nothing is
anyone's fault but mine
um
yeah like if you're annoying me it's my
fault yeah because I yeah haven't helped
you develop as a person to not annoy me
yeah I don't know but yeah so everything
is my extreme ownership with everything
three liters of water a day yeah
digesting positive content every day and
uh working out every single day and no
Dairy no uh bread no sugar
The Sweet Spot is I bought myself a
calendar and I'm gonna do this between
now and my birthday okay that's a two
minute it's like 60 something days yeah
so I'm doing it between now and my
birthday and I have the just above my
fridge the calendar is sat there okay in
my kitchen okay and every day I either
cross it or take or ticket Red Cross
green tick so I'm like this is like day
four now okay I've got my first day was
a cross but I'd already I was already
half this is how much accountability I
want to take I was already halfway
through the day when I decided this is
what I'm doing okay okay okay so I'd
already broken the date yeah before I'd
even discovered this thing I want to do
yeah and taking extreme ownership I was
like today's not yeah yeah I'm charging
it yeah I [__] up regardless of even
is before I started the thing today is a
cross so the day number one is across
every day since then it's been a tick
okay you don't [__] understand how
excited I get to do a tick I can imagine
you don't understand
imagine when you've made it through the
day you know where's my green pen right
where's my green box yeah yeah yeah I
love that I'm gassed for it I love that
so far I've got one cross and two ticks
nice when I get home tonight it's gonna
be the third tick okay I'm excited to be
done today
um well I haven't done any exercise
today but where am I going after this
Jiu Jitsu my friend with Tammy for like
an hour and a half say less so there so
that's my exercise for today
um I've already drank I drank a liter of
water when I woke up uh overall and then
by the time I finish this is my three
liters did you do so this will be gone
yeah
um
and yeah I've had no sugar no dairy uh
no pasta nothing today
um and yeah I know today's gonna be a
tick and I've already digested positive
content on the way down here nice um
even though this is positive content
right now but yeah bro and it's
fascinating well the visual
representation of these ticks and
Crosses I would advise even though I'm
only a few days in I would advise it to
everyone because it's also something
that I've told people to do in the past
when I was ptn I was like you should do
this with the calendar you should do
this
um and my thing is it's not that I have
to every day has to be a tick is if
between now and my birthday as long as
80 is ticks because you're gonna have
[__] ups yeah as long as 80 is ticks I
will be in a much better position than
when you don't have that visual
representation of this is what my hard
work looks like it's like that's when
people start saying this week's a
write-off yeah this day's a write-off
this week's a write-off yeah yeah
because you don't you've not seen how
hard you've worked yeah yeah you've not
realized that you've been doing nine
solid days of good [__] you don't
remember it like that and then you have
a bad weekend and you're like you you
have a bad weekend and then you're
hungover on Monday yeah and you're like
this weekend this is Tuesday yeah but if
you if you actually had to cross seven
more crosses on there I promise you
you're not saying this week's right yeah
yeah yeah Sunday yeah come Sunday I'm
back yeah I'm back bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah and the one thing I've allowed
myself as well is to make this actually
realistic is I haven't cut out alcohol
most people count alcohol I haven't okay
because one I barely drink and two the
only time I drink is when we're in
highly social situations and I struggle
socially so I want to obviously for
business reasons I need to be in social
situations if I tell myself I'm not
drinking yeah um I promise you we I
won't be I mean yeah I know I just won't
be going or if I am going I will be a
shell of myself yeah yeah I won't enjoy
it yeah yeah um so the drink can stay
because I [__] never drink anyway
okay
um but yeah bro I'm so excited every day
to get put that tick on and also on top
of that is just like
also in a fun way for me is also super
demoralizing to look up there feel like
when I'm starving I'm thinking I want
sugar I want none that yeah that's why I
sit there I want some lemon yeah yeah
yeah and I look up there and I think
I've been doing this for four years I
know it feels like I've been doing this
for literally forever I deserve for
chocolate and then you look up and
there's only two ticks up there you're
like Jesus Christ yeah this is gonna
take forever yeah this is no way but I
know once I've been doing it for two
weeks if I can see two weeks of ticks on
that that will motivate me to keep going
it's fascinating bro I'm enjoying it so
fast it's only in a few days but I'm
[__] enjoying it so far yeah so
that's that's my new accountability dang
that's fascinating man that's very
fascinating because visual represent
visual representation matters highly
yeah because I um mine is nowhere near
as Extreme as yours but what I do is uh
when we first started the PT thing with
um uh Terence I it's something I've
never done before but it's something I
don't know why I haven't I write
everything down that I do I write all my
exercises I write
um the weights that I've used and how
many actual reps I've done and then I
flip back between every page obviously I
do the same exercise week and week out
yeah yeah I just flip back to see how
heavy I was doing last week bro that's
what I need to do is step up so that's I
Did It For My push session well I've
done it for my push session almost every
week like increasing send me a leg same
like and I just see it I'm thinking damn
I'm actually getting even though I might
not see myself getting here yeah I'm
clearly getting stronger that's because
I'm doing more and more and more yeah so
yeah it feels just that visual
representation alone is perfect for me
do you know what I've been doing as well
on top of this because I need to work
every 45 minutes a day yeah yeah
um what I've started doing as well which
I've enjoyed especially on legs because
I hate doing legs what I've been doing
this week what I've been doing this week
is write another workout yeah and then
I'm putting a timer on my phone 45
minutes I have to get the workout done
in this 45 minutes
makes perfect sense fam I did it for
legs the other day I promise I didn't
finish
I was doing front squats and the alarm
started ringing and I was like I've got
like four more sets bro I've been
lounging too much so next week I'm gonna
do the same thing I need to finish any
exercise where you're in I was I was
like 80 of the workout done so now I
know next week when I go in there you
can't yeah no rest go go go get it done
do you do legs on Sundays when it's
quiet
um I it depends my it depends how my
week's gone because like I need adequate
rest between body parts so like
depending on when I'm working out and
when we're working and when we've got
events and stuff like that my rotation
changes but I have been trying to do
legs on Sundays when it's quiet but my
gym is it doesn't matter if I'm just
quite online there's so much equipment
in my gym it doesn't it really doesn't
matter if it's quiet or not
um but now I know like [__] cool I
couldn't finish it last week now this
week maybe I need to superset these ones
I need to do these ones back to back I
need to not rest between this and this
and I'm push push push push push push
push I will look like Iron Man from
visit 100. you will get a dirty pump I
Promise You by my birthday I'm gonna
look like I'm a human being bro that was
my thought process when I started
started this um 10 meeting because I
think 10 weeks would be
next week oh raw I think so yeah 10
weeks that's flown by James yeah I
calculated my technical I was thinking
by my birthday I'm gonna look like a
different human being I feel great but I
don't I wouldn't say I look massively
different but I feel better so and
that's obviously down to my
accountability yeah so question if you'd
have the calendar the entire 12 um
entire 10 weeks if you'd have that
calendar what percentage between ticks
and Crosses do you think you would have
had in terms of nutrition not
necessarily what I'm doing not in terms
of like the content stuff yeah but the
the diet that he set you and the
training that you sent you just from
those two things how many ticks and
Crosses do you think you'll have
um
if I'm being honest with myself
I think I would probably have a
I want to say a 60 40 maybe 65 35 split
65 for ticks I think six five maybe 60
because I remember there were weeks I
probably trained twice okay and if I'm
training twice I know my my diet is poor
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so if
I'm being honest with myself probably a
60 40 split which is when you put it
that way it's not good enough it's not
good enough or you put it that way it's
not good enough
thank you so good enough it's not good
enough because I've been claiming I've
been saying I've dropped x amount same
every week yeah yeah I was 102 when I
started I'm still on 98.7 I've been
saying 98 for the past three and four
weeks now I should have been 95 by now
some
yeah
it's not enough I'm vexed it's not
enough
you said you had McDonald's this week
yeah I forgot about that
right you've got a thread for us yeah
yeah I do that's hilarious
yeah so I got sent this little thread um
bear people send it to me so they may
have sent it to you as well I'm not too
sure so the context is we asked the
internet for their favorite nicknames
and they didn't disappoint oh I've never
I've never seen this one okay so I'll
read each one my mate used to my mate
used to work with a fella called Keith
he has an eye missing they all called
him keth
wow
I used to be a cop
one of the other cops was really small
they called him laptop as he was a small
PC I've seen that one so I've seen that
one that's a it's a bit stake laptop
yeah
a friend of mine works in a big Bank
there was a guy there named Wayne Bruce
they used to call it Man-Bat
that's funny
that was actually funny that was funny
bro I've got a couple more there's a guy
at work with one leg shorter than the
other The Lads call him a sniper's
nightmare
because
yeah
hahaha
nothing red visualization of this team
is jokes to me because if I'm a sniper
I'm a forgive it stay still [__] know
I'm living oh my God sniper's nightmare
walk symmetrical bro what are you doing
what's wrong with your Cadence
your gate is so off
oh there's choice
uh I know I know a guy who's an
electrician one of the old boys who used
to work with is about 70 they call him
Jurassic spark that's clever that is
clever
um that was the last one wow man fat man
don't speak to me like that snipers
nightmares
probably not I wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't I wouldn't sniper's nightmare
yeah yeah that's hilarious [__] you bro
actual it's not a nickname that's bully
that is bullying that is bullying in the
workplace that is Bully HR oh [__] yeah
facts bro oh I've had all the nicknames
brother as to this day
um right let's do a quick Last of Us
recap from this week so we've got
episode five episode five heartbreak bro
episode five you're not seen it
Remington
have you seen Ellis
of course that's what I like to hear man
so episode five quick breakdown we saw a
little flashback on as to why um I can't
remember the white chick was looking for
this spreader uh this guy has got uh is
it was it his younger brother or was it
little brother yeah little brother he's
um dumb he's dumb he can't speak so he
can only hear so he writes with a with I
think was actually very genius as well
by the way this thing that this thing is
yeah yeah I'm thinking how else are
man's Gonna Make You Know permanent and
then obviously it flashes back it
flashes back from there then a fast
forward to when they actually meet um
Joel and uh Ellie Joel and Ellie and the
story just develops the story just
absolutely develops and obviously the
peakless moment is the moment we're
going to talk about in a second but or
the two peak moments actually
um but the first Peak moment brawl I was
I was just sitting there watching it
right this is obviously when um the um I
can't remember his name but the dancing
interest-looking brother and his brother
yeah yeah yeah and no Sam's the kid
right I can't remember both of their
names I can't remember either of their
names yeah
um they were hiding by the car yeah
and then obviously the car crashes into
the thing and it started to go down and
you think what's going on and then
obviously Joel is sniping
from the yard and then Rumble Rumble
Rumble chaos the way these man sprinted
out everything I sat up I couldn't
believe how fast they came out there bro
I sat the [__] I couldn't believe it
brother bro I was like oh yeah yeah if I
was I would have survived that it's 28
Days Later bro because that's actual
jump scare yeah the reaction yeah no no
no no to dip off no no no no you're
nabbing me ASAP instantly because as
soon as I try and take off it's one of
them ones yeah it's literally what it is
they're nabbing my ankles because it's
been I've been doing this for days you
might have been underground for 15 years
15 years they came out with such speed
it was terrifying to me that was a very
good scene yeah I didn't expect that
because I just expected the big red to
come out because that's what they've
t-shirts
yeah yeah if they showed this whole
Rampage I wouldn't expect it yeah bro I
wasn't expecting them to run out like
that I couldn't believe it and then when
the big [__] came out this is
ripping him heads off
tore it apart yeah it didn't his
strength didn't make sense because I'm
thinking what's next like how are we
meant to defeat this man that's all I
kept talking about this one doing
nothing he wasn't the bullets weren't
doing nothing yeah ricocheting
everywhere yeah yeah absolutely yeah
it's mad bro I much preferred this
obviously there was a lot more um
action in this episode but I preferred
this storyline to
um episode three with um the two the gay
one the gay couple yeah this one was
really good this one might be my
favorite even outside of that actually
yeah yeah that storyline is really good
episode was really good it might be my
favorite yeah really good I might ever
take the gay one as well it was really
good I loved episode three
I know I loved it but yeah this one
might be that might be the one and you
know what's actually dread so obviously
homeboy got bit
homeboy obviously little kid got bit
yeah
um it was dread and then
um Ellie Ellie rubbed her blood on him
was that my blood's medicine yeah first
of all don't lie to me but obviously lie
to me because I can't I need to sleep
yeah I'm a child yeah yeah yeah I'm a
child and I need some hope yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but also yeah don't FIB
yeah when she said that I was like damn
yeah it was crazy and the way the way
she sat up in the morning was like say
she believed that was gonna work because
she she went to sleep with man in there
yeah yeah are you crazy are you
literally crazy
you went to sleep with homeboy in there
nah that was nuts and when he got bit
it's so it's not even funny but it's
like facts to me
when we realized he got bit I was
thinking this whole episode's been a
waste of time because obviously the
story from the Big Brother yes the whole
reason he's on the run is because little
man had leukemia and he had to rat out
home the home girl's brother the leader
of the resistance give him up to get the
leukemia medicine to save his brother's
life then they go through this whole run
around this whole thing to save the
brother to save himself for all this
stuff just at the end for the brother to
get bit I was thinking oh I'll talk
myself what a waste of time and then he
he had to shoot his own brother and then
was like what Rob done bang once said
what have I done Joseph give me the gun
give me the gun give me the guy get it
again I thought he's going to pop Joel
same same he's not in his right mind
episode incredible episode first of all
shot
what a shark for someone who's never
killed anyone
facts facts facts yeah yeah took your
brother's head off but yeah straight I
just don't know what
why would ah
I think that's the only choice that is
the only choice yes stop yourself
there's just there's literally no point
carrying on
Joel Joel wanted to scrap the you get
off Ellie fast yeah
brother bro shut the floor
don't touch my brother bro fam I
wouldn't know what you said give me a
weapon because I'll kill all human get
him offer facts facts bro oh episode
they acted that so well so perfectly so
well great they really really really
encapsulated like the Panic of feeling
yes indeed indeed this whole like
I need to kill my brother for Joel to
run in and was like you stop I need to
understand what's going on this is too
much information I don't even know he
was big yeah what the [__] is going on
no one knew but her a man said are you
going to stay in the are you going to
stay in the room with me oh no he said
stay awake with me yeah are you gonna
stay awake with you first of all yes
because you're gonna kill me yeah facts
I'm not going sleep second of all I'm
not saying anywhere with you I'm saying
awake in there
do your business I'm not rubbing blood
on your nasty leg either I don't know
how well this immunity works I'm not
risking this mad absolutely mad right
we're gonna finish on a trash news today
yeah yes we are right
um a new bill proposed on Beacon Hill
which is a um uh prison would allow
Massachusetts prisoners to donate their
organs for a reduced sentence
the legislation would give people
anywhere from 60 days to a year off
their prison sentence on the condition
that the incarcerated individual has
donated bone marrow or organs
the ACT to establish the Massachusetts
incarcerated individual bone marrow and
organ program is sponsored by oh that's
all Jarvis so long story short long
story short you can get your sentence
reduced in Massachusetts if you donate
organs yeah man if your organs or bone
marrow
now my question to you is
you're doing a 60 stretch no not even 60
is too much because I feel like if I say
60 you're not again
pointless pointless
you're doing a young five oh you're
doing it so that's now we're talking 20
yeah yeah yeah yeah you're doing a young
five right and you've done
you've done it's it's Blackbird you've
done like one and a bit and you're
losing your mind bro okay you've
accustomed yeah your first few years
yeah yeah yeah yeah but the power you
had in the first years is dwindling yeah
yeah yeah it's dwindling yeah yeah and
you're on like you've got 3.5 left well
you get are you giving up and what are
you giving up
and if you give up let's say you you
give up some substantial not bird marrow
whiskey will give you maybe six months
off but if you give up an organ like a
kidney yeah you're getting maybe 1.5 and
we're extending the rules for you okay
um
I will free up the bone marrow but
you're not having a vital organ of mine
I promise you that now you're not having
a vital organ of me I'd be too scared
bro there's a [__] film I watched the
other day I love this move I've seen
that four times it's called
um sugar what's it called and said sugar
yeah I don't know we've been swearing
today I don't know why I just said sugar
it's called
um it's called Andrew Garfield in it
yeah and it's got
um Kate Winslet in it and it's got
um
some other things in it yeah Ellis do
your thing do that job let's see who's
the bigger researcher out of two
yeah
uh no not cake Winslet um oh no no no
I'm wrong I'm wrong it's not Kate
Winslet it's uh the girl from parts of
the Caribbean what's her name
oh Keira Knightley not Kate Winslet
yeah what's the chords he's got it never
let me go ah yeah in in Ellis's defense
on that one he hadn't even typed Kate
Winslet
all right say less Keira Knightley right
this is why red makes the big box
um so uh never let me go bro never let
me go oh my God so it's a movie about
um there's this school there's a school
uh there's schools all over the place
they live in a like a
basically a dystopian future where
um it's in the future but they're like
time like modernization time in terms of
like uh technology and stuff is like
from the 70s or something like that okay
80s like C type of thing
so they're in the future but they've got
no technology yeah they're in the future
but they're like from when our mum and
dads were kids
um that's like what the cars look like
and all that they've got no computers so
anyway
um
their kids they grew up in school and
basically they realize as they get older
um they're from these like special
schools
long story short all these kids are
clones they've developed cloning
technology to cure all of basically all
of the world's illnesses okay and what
they do is these they're basically
cattle
okay and once they hit 18 they start
chopping organs out of you
they start chopping organs out of you
and then you make it like one two times
and then you just die they just start
taking organs until you die basically
that's your whole life that's your
life's purpose is to give organs until
you die
oh it's a dark movie but it's wonderful
okay it's truly one let me go never let
me go it's fantastic okay so let's I'll
give a watch um
I watched a movie recommended a few
times on the show the other day the hunt
uh with mads whatever his name mads
Mickelson yeah yeah the pedo movie yeah
yeah yeah you finally watched it I
watched it the other day isn't it how
you manage not to text me it's crazy
yeah Clara's a little bit
Clara isn't it yeah the little
four-year-old little prick yeah what a
movie amazing isn't it the internal
conflicts for him not to even say what
actually happened yes bro crazy to me
bro it's a fantastic amazing movie I
love I've seen that movie three times as
well so fantastic amazing
obviously from when I saw him in
Hannibal I was like yeah you're an
accident oh bro from the crazy bit on
that is that after all of it blows over
at the end and then the bullet flies
past his head and you can see the
figurines just run off into the night no
no I'm moving down I would have moved on
before nothing I don't know why he sat
through that yeah he's got heart yeah
yeah he's got heart it was crazy bro but
anyway this thing uh yeah you're not
taking fire all good from me so bone
marrow six months and that's what we're
gonna have to do because I promise you
you're not taking it from that's scary
this is this is where things stop this
is where things start getting shaky this
is my things that start shaking because
then they start passing bills and
they're like why are we even giving
these prisoners a choice
yeah and your prisoner can patting him
and he's saying no take it
he's incarcerated he's got no rights or
joints take it
the [__]
facts bro that's crazy
facts are not on this Rehabilitation
talk take it from him
why should he live and he dies take the
marrow I'm not going to ask you twice
I think that one is still more fair into
people being potential prisoners oh bro
the streets will be clean the streets
will be clean bro I'm not going in jail
you can't go pen so you can take my lung
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no yeah
wow bro this is the beginning of the end
produced sentence for freeing up organs
bro you know if when you uh donate a
kidney like you're mucked you know oh
I'm not surprised yeah it's not even
meant to have two yeah exactly yeah we
have Ultra have two for a reason you can
survive on one you're meant to have you
can barely survive on one apparently
your uncle days are gone by the way
surprise me there's bad things like
vigorous exercise all these things
apparently that's a rap
you do not have the same life with one
kidney as you do too so if I ever give
you a kidney thank me
oh I would yeah oh I would because I
don't see why you would have to give me
again I never know touch wood
yeah yeah God forbid yeah that's [__]
crazy scary today I want to see how this
develops yeah same same I couldn't
believe it I couldn't believe that when
I read that but yeah anyway guys that
was a good that was a long one as well
that's a good episode
um as always thank you very much head on
over to patreon.com shits and gigs for
more laughs
um thank you for always hanging around
with us
um this is a blessing and uh yeah love
love
[Music]
good